hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have suggested it's a game
from the chest that comes computer Chess
Championship stockfish vs. Komodo from
the semi-finals the final remaining
engines are Leela chest zero stop fish
Commodore or Komodo and a little inch 9
I have no idea what that is having been
following what's been going on in the
engine world for a while but it features
a most interesting endgame position so
as usual when it's a game between two
very strong engines the positions are
really difficult what the games are
usually boring so we're only gonna focus
on the situations that interest us mere
mortals if you will so without further
ado let's check it out stock which opens
with B for that we have Knight to f6 c4
and the g6 of Commodore goes for D Kings
Indian defense sorry about that
we have g3 Bishop to g7 and Bishop for
the g2 so just continuing development
with castles Knight to c3 and b6 going
for the for the main line we have Knight
to f3 and c5 now most popular also but
by nowadays standards with d5 grabbing
more space in the center and east sex
now now we have castles by stockfish eek
after sandy 5c captures and rook to e8
and here rook that II won both players
just continuing development a6 preparing
b5 n des doctors of course stops at we
have a for Knight B to d7 and Bishop to
f4 now grabbing control over the e5
square and Knight to g4 and here a stock
which grabs more space on the Queen side
on the Queen side by playing a 5 very
nice
so in life if b5 r b6 you can always
capture on b6 and here there is actually
one game in the database between human
players pan tawa harikrishna versus
Dorado Bailey from 2019 and grant
Fida grant Swiss 27 was played and her
accretion was able to win that game with
white but here we have a knight dt v and
it is as i move 13 that we have a
completely new game so night the e4 by
stockfish looks
a bit risky putting the knight in front
to look like this but this night doesn't
have any useful discoveries if night
chapters with check then Bishop or pawn
captures also protects the knight on e4
so here H 6 and now Queen to see one
with a double attack on the h6 pawn with
g5 now for single trade on e5 with
Bishop characters on e5 Knight captures
on e5 and now just Knight captures on e5
with Bishop characters on e5 and night
the b2 as stops which is expecting Queen
to f6 to go with a double attack on the
beat upon so nice to see four will guard
against that and also it's a it's a very
nice outpost for the night keeping
around at b6 square keeping an eye on
the pawn here in the making room for
whites to push e for so Queen to f6 with
a double attack on the pawn here also a
nice developing move Knight to c4
attacking the bishop while now defending
the b2 point and the Bishop to d7 a
black continues development we've looked
a three a very nice rook lifted by
Stoppers preparing efore and rook to e3
so this way stalkers will double rooks
on the e-file Bishop to b5 now putting
pressure on the night saying that okay I
can capture and then eliminate your pawn
here and win the game and White's next
move is pretty much forced Knight
captures any 5 we have rook captures on
e5 and now II for s plan that the roof
is coming to e3 we have group 88 black
also doubles up on the e-file and now
rook 83 we're sawfish nicely positions
these pieces on dark squares as
comedor has a light square bishop so g4
saying you're not about to push f4 or h4
anytime soon I'm just preventing that
with g4 so a stockfish of course goes
after the g4 pong with h3 but now h5
keeping the pawn on g4 Quinta c3 now so
now if this rook moves you will be able
to gobble up the Queen so Queen g7 and
here h4 stop which causes the position
on the King side and now we we go into
something that I like to call the the
dance of the engines it's something
humans do as well but when engines do
it's just weird so now we have a look at
rook 8 the e 7 we have King 2h to
improving the position Queen h8 now we
have Queen to d2 also just repeating
king a queen to g7 Queen back to c3 we
have Queen back to h8 and the Queen to
d2 and the Queen to g7 again and now if
stockfish doesn't want a draw by
threefold repetition he has to play
something else
so Queen to d1 now allowing black to go
for this f5 break in the centrist so f5
stockfish doesn't want to draw but he
doesn't consider this to be all that bad
for white so he allows it we have Queen
to see one now and a nice straight F
captures on e4 we have rook captures
captures captures we have captures and
Bishop captures so everything trades
down stockfish decides that this is okay
for him in the Queen to e5 now now
putting pressure on the bishop here but
also on the BT upon here seeing what do
you do here but stocks which finds Queen
to f4 saying okay let's trade Queens or
if you capture the pawn here then my
bishop the g6 will be very very strong
threatening check and mate so you would
have to go back but then I just gobble
up all of your Queen side a king size
pawns and then I'm just better so by
grabbing upon your you are actually
losing two pawns
so after Queen to f4 comodo decides that
we're gonna capture on f4 at the mess of
White's pawn structure we have G
captures on f4 and now Bishop to eight
and Bishop to f5 now at some point
Bishop to f7 is coming so you do want to
have the option of blocking it will
Bishop to e6 but after Bishop to e7
not Bishop to e6 right away but first
stockfish plays f3 he gets rid of his
past he gets rid of his doubled F pawn
to mess up a black's pawn structure and
now if you go for the d5 pawn then after
all of the trades here you will have to
pass points you're on the Kings side the
King will go to help out with the with
these guys here and white should White
will be better
so after f3 g captures on f3
comedor captures the pawn messes up its
pawn structure and now Bishop to e6 just
offering a trade here and you can never
trade here for example captures captures
King f8
you're gonna go King g3 and now after
King g7 f5 and this is of course
completely winning for white as the two
to pass bonds are now connected so
that's in a component game that's
winning so f2 instead that point is
going either way so my engines at some
point I decide to give it up kingi to
King g7 and King captures an f2 we have
king to f6 and now f5
so again if there are any beginners here
watching you cannot win a pawn here it's
the same as before if captures captures
and captures when you have two points
here the King can never capture the back
at the backwards pawn because if you do
then you can no longer stop the b-pawn
from promoting to a queen so after f5
we've burst back to be 8 and now King
III white just starts improving the
position King e5 black first reaches the
center so black the position of the
black king is much more active but be
sure to see it now now white goes after
the Queen side pawns but it's not a
problem that's up to b5 you're gonna
give up this point but you are gonna
eliminate this pawn and this in fact
wouldn't be all that great for white if
characters captures you will not have
any more ways of winning this with white
since everything is nicely nicely
blocked so after Bishop to b5 white
returns Bishop to e6 he says I'm not
giving up the pawn bishop back to eh buy
black and now Bishop to c8 once again
now white doesn't mind if black captures
here then you're gonna capture with
check and also win the a six point and
create a passed upon so that would be
well for white but better back to b5 and
again we have a little dance here
so if stockfish is not interested yet
again in repeating in the position and
accepting a draw he has to play
something else and here he does he
pushes f6 giving up upon to improve the
position for of asking to grab more
space so k king captures and king to f4
and okay you've improved the position of
your king but how are you how are you
crossing this this is a very very hard
to do if at all possible but okay Bishop
to e2 I just keeping with the bishop
here with defense of the these two pawns
here
that's what captures on b7 you are going
to give
that guy up either way and now Bishop
the c-4 puts pressure on this point here
Bishop the c6
and now we're back to f1 so black is
asking what what are we doing here the
show back to e 8 and now bush of the e2
we have King to e3 attacking the bishop
but now pushed back the g4 with Bishop
to a four and now kink the g7 again they
started their little dance of engines we
have butchered back to yet and now King
to f6 Russia back to a four and Malcolm
to g6 with Bishop the c6 and now Bishop
the c8 just defending the pawn bishop th
check King to h6 defending and King f4
once again grabbing more space but you
are not crossing any of these squares
anytime soon so Bishop to g4 just
continuing the shove the c6 and now came
to g6 with King to e3 Russia back Russia
back to C 8 and verse of the EA check
once again King age 6 repeating once
again King a4 and Buster back to g4 so
twice we've reached the position Russia
back to a four and now King to g6 we
have kinked III and now Bishop to h3 by
their Komodo Bishop - I ate with check
King to h6 and now Russia back to a4 we
have king to g7 King to f4 and now came
to f6 so again the opposition has been
reached Bishop back to d1 now going
after the pawn this way King g6
defending and Bishop to e2 now
threatening the a6 pawn so bush of the
CA defending and Bishop to d3 with check
we have King to f6 again saying what are
we doing here and measure back to a2 e2
going after the pawn king g6 Bishop d3
checking of 6 and Bishop to f1 now you
have to be careful not to repeat
positions King g6 and now Russia back to
E - we have Bishop the b7 putting
pressure on the pawn here Bishop d3
check King to f6 and now again bishop to
eat you're saying okay let's straight at
this point for this point but Komarov
says no thank you I'm just gonna
continue repeating King g6 we have a
kink that efore now defending and Bishop
to see
eight we have kinked the ìiî brush up
the b7 King to a four and now the ship
back to c8 King back to e3 better back
that b7 and now King to d2 again asking
what do you do here do you want to
capture this pawn and trade it for this
spawn again comedor not interested he
just goes back Bishop to c8
King the c3 we have King to h6 and now
as pretty much in any any move that
you'd want to do would be repeating the
position so you might as well try
something else before so a pawn move and
now we go at it again
see capture son before King captures
again there's no way of crossing the
position here as the points create a
wall against the book against the white
king so King g6 kamala says okay let's
let's just enjoy ourselves with King to
b3
let's go back to b7 attacking the pawn
king c4 Russia back to c8 and now King
b3 Russia back the b7 we have King the
c3 now asking again are you interested
in the trade now King h6 Commodore just
repeats with Bishop to d3 and
kink the g7 now we have King to d4
Bishop to c8 and now the shabak the e2
going after the pawn king g6 defending
Bishop d3 check King to g7 and now
Bishop to e2 we have King to g6 again
King to d3 and now King to h6 we have
King to e4 grabbing more space in the
center but King back to g6
King to f4 with Bishop the b7 attacking
the pawn and now again Bishop d3 check
King f6 and Bishop to c4 now defending
the pawn bishop the c8 and now comes in
Bishop to d3 once again repeating the
position we have Bishop to b7 and
incredible as it seems this position is
winning for white it's it's it's
incredible that such things are even
possible interest when you think you've
seen everything then something like this
happens and someone tells you yes this
is winning for white so if you haven't
seen it by any chance
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea here for white
while I give you a couple of second
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on putting black in
absolute loop swung and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop to f5 this is the way you do
it you force black to capture the pond
now because well this is it will just be
winning for white so what's the idea if
you can if you don't capture let's first
explore the option that Komodo says ok
I'm not I'm just not capturing that we
just go back Bishop to a 8 and now the
shove the c8 you go after the pond and
pretty much not much for you to do you
you're gonna have to capture and Bishop
captures and you've created a passed
pawn here which will now be winning for
white so might as well capture it right
away without giving white any any extra
Tempe so Bishop captures and if I was
played but now Bishop to d3 okay you go
after the pawn bishop the b7 defending
and now Bishop to c4 this is this is how
you achieve victory here again you black
doesn't have all that many moves if you
move the king and allow King g5 to
eliminate this pawn then that's just
game so you might try the five but d5 is
also also bad because of Russia back to
e 2 now you're asking do you wanna move
the bishop somewhere and allow me to
capture this pawn do you allow me to
capture this pawn or do you defend the
pawn and then allow King e5 and once
you've allowed King if five then that's
just lost whatever you play and not much
you can play King has to keep an eye on
this point you're gonna go king d4 king
g6 king c5 and after let's say king h6
king b6 and now this is just losing
bishop the c8 you're gonna play King to
c6 eliminate this point and black might
even try and do something like this but
you can still go after the pawn king g6
you're gonna capture it and the next
you're just gonna bring your king to b6
win this pawn and then win the game so
that's what happens if you go for d5
seems like a reasonable move but it's
really not so king g6 are repeating this
should be back to e to enter now push it
back to c8 but now Bishop to f3 taking
away the b7 Square from black Bishop so
what do you do now
Tripta f5 not much you can do but now
King III you're not you're not in a rush
to go after Bishop to b7 you have to
prevent Bishop to d3 first so Buster
back to c8 and now King to d4 Bishop
back to g4 now offering a trade bishop
the e4 check with King to f7 and now
Bishop to d3 going after the pawn and
here problem is if you go bash up the c8
defend upon them king d5 and after King
to e7 king c6 and again it's a similar
position to the one we've had but you're
gonna play King b6 when the spawn and
win the game since this point is much
more advanced than this spawn so after
Bishop to d3 we have king te 8 but now
finally Bishop captures on a6 you grab
the pawn king d8 we have kinked sorry
and not d5 we have kinked up efore now
going going after the King side King to
c7 and now Bishop to b5 creating a wall
against the black King here nicely King
v8 and now Kings to f4 we have King back
to c7 and now Bishop t8 so now you can
also play this and grab this bond while
still creating a wall here against the
black King so he cannot occur approach
your pawn d5 by black but now King e5
with gush of the f3 defending the pawn
but now again Bishop to b5 with King to
be 7 and now King to d6 we kink the b8
but now king c6
this trick does nothing so not much
point in doing it King a7 not allowing
the the King to go to be 6 but now just
Bishop to d3
King back to b8 but now came to b6 and
now finally that you will out looking to
reach b6 not much to do here Bishop to
e4 was played now Bishop to b5 but still
it's it's an incredibly impressive
endgame we have d4 and now a6 preparing
a 7 with check d3 we have a 7 with check
King to a 8 and now okay it's a question
how do you break through since the
bishop is controlling this diagonal it's
actually not quite that difficult Bishop
the a6 you give black a move once again
it's everything about to swung
d to buy black not much you can do you
can never move the bishop if you move
the bishop from this diagonal it's just
checkmate
so d2 was played but now but should be
back to e to guarding this square and
also controlling the h5 pawn and here D
one night was played engines sometimes
are funny like this they they go for an
under promotion instead of a queen since
it doesn't really matter I guess it's
easier for them to calculate since
there's even though to a human it's
irrelevant to an engine there are less
lines to calculate if you bring your
knight and it's just the same so I guess
you know it saves the resources but ok
bishop character sandy won either way
now we have Bishop back the b7 now you
you cannot hold everything you cannot
hold this pawn since you would receive
mate
so best trip to b7 but now Bishop
captures on h5 Bishop the c6 Bishop the
c6 by black saying are you may be
interested in this bishop so I can grab
the pawn but we have rushed back to d1
just preparing to put the past pawn so
rush up to h1 we have h5 Bishop to G to
H 6 and here Bishop back to h1 but it
doesn't matter because if you go for
Bishop to c4 to cover the h7 square of
course you will see how white wins
without even pausing the video I am sure
of course yes congratulations to
everyone
h7 you just kick the bishop away from
this diagonal so next move it's either
checkmate with with the queen or the
rook and if you capture it's just Bishop
to f3 mate well once you block it okay
then it's Bishop captures I mean for
mate so black just played Bishop to h1
like I said engines are funny like that
h7 Bishop to d5 we have h8 Queen this
comes with Czech Russia blocks and Queen
captures and g8 and this is now
checkmate
but it all came to that moment of that
beautiful after Bishop to b7 to that
Bishop the f5 move and yes we will see
this one once again in slow motion there
you have it Bishop f5 brilliant
brilliant stuff so like I said we don't
often show an engine games here on this
channel
we do sometimes show a neural net
against an engine so as those are a bit
more interesting to me but when it's
when it features and exciting endgame
like this we are definitely going to
show it so there we have it that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank David Kaiser as Sam
Mendelsohn Alicia Meltzer expanding your
world and Don Crawford for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos Sharon
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day